[Music]
hey welcome to every damn day today's
the start of the full NFL preseason
games are kicking off tonight and
there's something historic happening on
two teams for the first time ever there
are male cheerleaders angly please throw
up that tweet this comes from Napoleon
Ginnie's who's going to be joining the
Rams he says still can't believe I'm one
of the first males in history to be a
pro NFL cheerleader on his Twitter he's
very excited we actually have two former
dancers in our mitts Hannah why don't
you guys please catch us up on your own
personal dance history and then tell me
what you think of this I was captain of
my high school dance team I bring it up
where I can and I looked into actually
being a Dallas Cowboy Cheerleader and
they only make $50 a game yeah I have a
very long history I am auditioned for my
high school dance team every year and
every year they did not take pressure is
the only person who auditioned every
[Applause]
who also got cut from the high school
sport it's just like really courageous
of you keep going out here I'd sure like
I was always bad yeah
wherewithal to like continue to just be
just rejected again and again what's
where were you cut from I was cut from
baseball soccer
I quit track after a day just running
cross-country I quit after I realized I
was just running what else do you just
run in I quit that Sports 2 main one
okay sure yeah fifty dollars a day that
was in 2005 I looked into it now it's
seventy-five to a hundred and fifty per
game but they're also required to go to
other events and they also have to
practice and they're only paid for the
game so for the whole season they were
30 to 40 hours a week and they only make
between a thousand and three thousand
one internship basically yeah and they
talked about that they have to pay for
their own products right and maybe
they'll strike it big and end up with an
NFL player I guess like there is so
they're not supposed to do that there's
very strict rules about they have
probably supposed to make any money
today also I don't know if they do it
for all of them but they also have to
sell magazines or I'm sorry calendars Oh
cookies are the Girl Scouts is just the
Girl Scouts that we talked about
they also have to hae to audition it's
like 75 dollars to auditions yeah maybe
they'll treat them like equals
I think it's nice that there's male
cheerleaders because now there are
finally men employed by the NFL that
won't suffer brain damage
I I read an article and say what it's
2014 and Men's Journal like called male
cheerleaders it was looking at college
cheerleaders but some of the toughest
men in college sports because you have
to be very strong they did equipping and
it talked about how they a lot of the
times in practice get hit in the head oh
yeah flipping cheerleaders in the nation
knocked out so they're gonna give
concussive my my college roommate was on
the cheerleading team in college and she
got a concussion oh I think it's cool
but also the NFL cheerleaders aren't
doing all the flips and stuff I hope
they'd start to incorporate like
throwing the window anything yeah watch
the game no no no I've been to plenty of
these and they make $100 a game so
they're just kind of doing this they're
not really depends on the squad I think
some are more just pure dance and then
some do the actual leg flip I want to
see the I mean we should be throwing
these women 40 50 feet in the air just
we should launch him like they shoot
t-shirts out just how many flips can you
do have you guys been to cyclone games
yes yes I have cheerleaders are
delightful because it's just like kids
from Staten Island
[Laughter]
Nome is the third act of the movie
they're gonna make about your son your
Tramp no promotion no cheerleading squad
know anything compares to like the fun
of like a minor league baseball game
like cheer promotion those people
because they just like throw ice at
strangers they do all kinds of crazy
like that realizes yeah that's one
of the things like one of the things is
like they just dump a bucket ice on you
if you get the question wrong or like
they like smack eggs on people go to the
cyclins game so I want to turn it to
something a little more serious right
now the NFL in general how are we
feeling about it
Ryan I know you brought up that maybe
you're boycotting the NFL I can't get
behind the NFL anymore because I'm like
grown up and so I understand that
they're like just exploiting people and
they're exploiting the cities and also
they moved the Rams from st. Louis to LA
oh he's just mad because st. Louis lost
their team and I was and then I realized
that there's plenty of legitimate
reasons to really hate them and if you
watch HBO real sports you're gonna know
exactly what I'm talking about there's
so many things wrong with the NFL I
can't support the machine are you back
on the diet coke train I can't help it
it's like I know psycho yeah the nice
Logan why not just do it if you're bored
no reason to sell it any are there no
how about it that's there like it just
have that
that's what that NFL campaign should be
you know why else go to college this is
Christian to the NFL I know it's not
official yet but I've been out for three
years that's three years they're still
making things issues that have nothing
to do one connecting it to the other and
they're not connected at all that's very
what are you gonna do I really don't
know I've been a good sport I played
tennis for example and in high start -
in high school I was the captain of the
drinkie cut team now I wouldn't get cut
and the whole discussion - I couldn't
find a good spot you be well tune back
in to see on a future episode Chris
maybe you can update us if you play
fantasy or not Jordan you have a shout
out for us yes yes yes Valentine says
honestly the only funny people on this
show are Natasha and Jordan the host
dude is alright two are just terrible
and then crusade or says I think you
meant Natasha and Chris Hanna is alright
- the rest are just terrible
Ryan replies guys I'm the only one you
have in
Hannah replies that's because you suck
if you notice I strategically positioned
myself to catch some of this heat we're
gonna do some different right now hi I'm
Hannah Dickinson and this is cheers to
you where I'm kicking off my first round
of the weekend by cheering to all the
people and stories that encouraged me to
drink cheers to you pulling for creating
a beer made from hot models vaginal
lactic acid it's only 5 euros you can
taste the sweat of actual polish factory
workers and side note if you think the
hottest part of the woman is when she
drips lactic acid you're doing it wrong
cheers to you Kourtney Kardashian and
Eunice Benzema on your breakup but what
why how you had so much in common you
were both rich and hot and alive cheers
to you Facebook for testing a new dating
feature I'm actually excited to be set
up by a site that's stolen all my
personal information
now I committed a guy who loves to shop
at Zara looks at pictures of my
ex-boyfriends girlfriend and who uses
food porn literally is it clear that I'm
masturbating to molten hot lava cake
cheers to you power fingering for being
the hottest new sex move it's when a man
fingers a woman and she doesn't
reciprocate or what I call it the Hannah
special AOL call me cheers to you Ruby
Rose for playing bat woman the first
lesbian superhero but are we surprised
that bat woman is a lesbian this only
superhero to wear a utility belt and
spend all of her time nestled in a moist
cave don't think so Cheers
the way I'm heading I'm gonna get cut
from this team - you still owe me for
your audition feed by the way being a
captain of a tennis - yes that even work
I don't understand what do you mean it's
just like you stand on the side you know
[Applause]
it works the same as any other sports
team can I ask
okay Hannah you're captain of the dance
- yeah how did you cut the dancing yeah
I picked out the uniform I picked up did
you I did anyone with a different design
but the original uniform and I like I
helped train the team it's impressive
you know what
[Laughter]
[Music]